let's talk about the best two foods for
anxiety now the Latin word for anxiety
means to choke so if you're being choked
you're going to experience anxiety but
let's see if we can come up with a good
definition of anxiety sometimes people
think it's stress right is it the same
thing as anxiety well stress is more
like uh some external pressure
that is out of your control so the more
you're being pressured by something
that's out of your control The more
stress you're gonna and you can have
anxiety with that for sure then you have
panic attacks right well that can be an
anxiety state for sure but Panic is more
like a high level severe fear situation
but I think the best word to describe
anxiety is worry you have problems
without a solution you're fixated on
certain problems or a problem that
sometimes occurs at night during the day
and you just can't not think about that
one problem so that's going to produce
worry or anxiety and everyone has their
limit of stress anxiety worry until they
become overwhelmed right and it's really
an individual thing and how much
tolerance a person has to be able to
deal with this anxiety or worry or
stress now if there's something missing
in your body okay which we're going to
discuss like you're deficient in a
certain thing your tolerance for anxiety
stress is going to be on the low side So
today we're going to talk about the two
best foods to increase your tolerance
for the things that you're anxious about
the things that you worry about so you
can do a million things to the body and
make it really strong it doesn't get rid
of the problems or anxieties but it
allows you to cope with them much better
okay so that is the purpose of this
video so on a physical level when you
have anxiety we have a couple different
parts of your body that are involved we
have the adrenal glands which are two
glands on top of the kidneys okay and
they have an outer part which produces
hormones and an inner part which
produces something called
neurotransmitters which are similar to
hormones but neurotransmitters are
Communications that travel to the
nervous system and hormones are
Communications that travel through your
blood or circulatory system and so we
have the adrenals and then there's
another thing too called the autonomic
nervous system so part of that is in the
adrenal glands okay but there's other
parts of your body that that they're
located as well and that would include
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous system is also
called the flight or fight system okay
so that's like the the stress system to
cope with stress and then the other
system is called the parasympathetic
which is also called rest and digest and
that helps you cope with the stress and
the autonomic nervous system uses
neurotransmitters to communicate and to
work correctly and so if we want to
build up the tolerance
to our stresses we want to understand
where neurotransmitters come from and
what can influence hormones well it just
so happens that your body does make
neurotransmitters and something else
inside your body makes neurotransmitters
and that would be your microbiome which
is pretty bizarre because you have these
non-body entities living inside your
body and outside your body that are
making neurotransmitters that are going
to greatly help you and in significant
quantities like even serotonin your
microbiome makes like 95 of Serotonin it
also makes your other neurotransmitters
like dopamine Gaba nor adrenaline they
make a lot of different B vitamins
especially B1 which is the most
important vitamin for stress your
microbiome also makes other vitamins
okay not just the B vitamins these micro
probes also make beneficial fats they're
called small chain fatty acids that help
you with your blood sugars that actually
feed your colon and these microbes
greatly regulate and help control your
hormones okay and your nervous system
and the central nervous system and your
immune system and the amount of bile
that you produce too and that's
something that helps you digest fats it
helps you extract that soluble nutrients
and it keeps microbes from growing in
the wrong place like the small intestine
so you can see these microbes are
extremely important for your health in
fact without them you would be very very
sick and they also have a great
influence over your mood okay
now a lot of people are stuck in this
trap
um when they go through stress they
crave this certain type of food called
Comfort Foods what is a comfort food or
comfort food is a food that provides
consolation which is basically means
comforting someone after some type of
stress or loss or disappointment it's
that food that provides consolation or a
feeling of well-being typically with a
high sugar or other carbohydrate content
so unfortunately when people go through
stress they they crave Comfort foods and
things like alcohol and the problem with
these carbohydrates and the alcohol is
not only does it deplete vitamin B1 to
act as a precursor for all of your
neurotransmitters it is the most
important vitamin for anxiety stress and
also the more carbohydrate that you eat
the more alcohol you drink
the more B1 is required and the other
thing about these carbohydrates and
sugar is they feed a certain type of
microbe in your gut that does not make
neurotransmitters that doesn't produce
anything good okay it ferments the sugar
it basically eats the sugar it loves the
sugar and it gives you inflammation
instead it gives you depression there's
been links to higher incidents of
getting bipolar when you feed sugar to
microbes it enhances the microbes that
don't give you good things okay it also
enhances candida fungus things like that
and these certain microbes that you feed
okay that start growing in larger
amounts will then send a communication
up to your brain causing you to want
more and more and more and so it's a
never-ending cycle that you eat the
sugar that then affects the microbiome
which then creates more stress and the
count of the stress you need more of
this carbohydrate and alcohol to give
you comfort and then the whole cycle
starts over and over and over again so
naturally the two foods that are the
most important in helping pull someone
out of a stress state or at least
increase their tolerance to stress so
they can deal with it so they don't get
overwhelmed
our number one
any food that provides like probiotics
okay good bacteria and number two foods
that provide
thymine B1 okay now there are foods that
provide thymine that also have a lot of
carbohydrates we're not talking about
those I'm talking about things like
nutritional yeasts okay that has like
the most B vitamins and so that would be
one recommendation those two foods are
the most powerful two foods to help pull
someone out of anxiety okay and stress
and a panic attack
now as far as Probiotic foods let's just
mention this for a second you have
fermented foods you have pickles kimchi
sauerkraut kefir okay you have those
Foods very very important on a regular
basis you should probably have a good
serving size every single day okay
something else that's quite fascinating
it's basically just raw vegetables so so
why would a raw vegetable help give you
probiotics well yes it does feed your
microbes fiber that helps build these
microbes but there's something else
actually very very interesting that I
recently found out about okay and I did
a video on this
um raw vegetables if they're healthy
contain their own
microbiome they are a form of probiotics
this explains how kimchi is made and how
sauerkraut is made and how pickles are
made if they're a fermented product okay
so let's just take sauerkraut where do
the microbes come
that help ferment sauerkraut okay well
yes there might be floating around the
air a little bit
um they might be on the surface of that
cabbage okay but mostly the microbes are
inside the Cabbage okay they're inside
because they're part of the microbiome
those are the family of microbes that
help to fermentation process they're
called lactobacillus microbes and so
this is why raw vegetables actually can
greatly help your microbiome okay
because they have microbes in them now
um on the flip side you may have gut
issues where you're doing carnivore and
you probably have seen this before where
vegetables are toxic and they can hurt
you well yeah if there's damage to your
gut okay but the vegetables in
themselves didn't originate this damage
to your gut okay they're not the culprit
of course you can't digest them now or
deal with them because there is some
other thing that destroyed or irritated
or damaged your gut like vegetable oils
which is very ironic because it's really
seed oils it's not like you're taking
vegetables and squeezing out the oil and
it's made a very difficult time
digesting anything with fiber including
vegetables but if you can digest real
vegetables that would be a good thing to
start fortifying your microbiome okay
and if you have fermented vegetables
that's a little bit easier to digest
sometimes because they have other
factors in there like they have certain
acids they have more concentrated
microbes and more enzymes to digest that
food so we have number one Probiotic
foods okay and vegetables number two
would be nutritional yeast nutritional
yeast is a product that is loaded with B
vitamins and you want to get the version
that's not enriched or fortified with
synthetic vitamins okay you just want to
get nutritional yeast in fact there's a
couple different ways that you can take
nutritional yeast you can sprinkle it
over your salad that's what I do
or you can get them as a supplement like
a little tablet but if you take anyone
that has anxiety and you give them
nutritional yeast within three minutes
they're going to feel a shift of
calmness of relaxation of a lot less
nervous tension internally okay it's a
great thing and I think until a person
tests that out they won't realize how
powerful that is in fact I'll put a link
down below of a video I did a
nutritional yeast but just read the
comments to see how people uh feel after
they take nutritional yeast in
relationship to stress it just makes
them feel calmer increase their
tolerance for stress and their ability
to cope with stress and so when solving
problems you can't be overwhelmed you
want to be able to tolerate life so you
can solve problems better in fact just
make it easier I put this nutritional
yeast video up right here check it out